one of the most accelerating cars in the
world
the Karmann Ghia by Volkswagen oh it may
look like a sports car but the Karmann
Ghia was far from it on its release in
1955 some journalists called it a parody
of a fast car which Christoph finds
pretty mean but in my hand back at the
at the back after all it has the most
powerful beetle engine of its time but
the jokes failed him Denham the Karmann
Ghia success anyway just two years later
in 1957 is beautiful convertible version
hit the roads copy over hunted
that said the car madea's performance
always trailed behind the promise of its
dynamic appearance although good looks
can get you a long way
Bostaph ooh just look at those curves
it's as if the car were cast from one
block of metal and it is the doors and
hood are bolted on but otherwise all the
body parts are welded together that
translates into high torsional stiffness
but on the other hand every single
repair job on this very rust prone body
requires a blowtorch keep that onyx many
people consider the Karmann Ghia the
best-looking Volkswagen of all time the
contours are perfection and a veritable
delight for the eyes
and there's a range of other loving
details that make the car a pleasure
just to look at let alone drive
the Carmen has 32 kilowatts of power and
Sprint's to 100 km/h in a leisurely 23
seconds top speed is 136 km/h Karmann
Ghia convertible cost a good three
thousand darks more than the technically
comparable export beetle but still
became a best-seller the convertible
version alone sold over 80,000 units
coupe a over 360,000 the car was
especially popular with the ladies
explains christophe earning at the not a
nickname housewives porsche it is 20
kilometers per hour faster than the
beetle thanks to its aerodynamics but
it's worlds away from a porsche is no
CFI 10/10
a marriage of spectacular design and
conventional production car engineering
the Karmann Ghia was the manifestation
of an ingenious concept one that
Volkswagen and Porsche would further
develop to a claim with the 914 and 924
models Karmann Ghia deserves a lot of
credit and christoph sighs it was a
breath of fresh air to West Germany's
post-war streets and the styling also
opened up opportunities for other
Italian designers in the German car
industry without this car we might never
have seen the Fat Tony BMW or the golf
designed by a giugiaro and that's reason
enough to call the Karmann Ghia a
milestone in automotive history
the Karmann Ghia was in production for
almost two decades from 1955 to 1974 it
was the first time automobile ultra was
available for the man on the street to
add next time on drive it open top
rocket Bentley Continental GTC speed and
a facelift for the Hyundai Veloster
Turbo